good morning everybody happy they say
Thursday happy Thursday welcome back
what just happened there are we live
there we go don't know what that was all
about you guys can see can you see can
you see can you see can you see
something that's happening on the live
there we go can you guys see yes we're
back all right I think it's when i'm
switching accounts it gets kind of funky
anyway here we are welcome to gratitude
livestream journal number 34 it's great
to be with you guys we do this daily and
it's fun to be back we share things that
we agreed before because grateful
entrepreneurs are happy entrepreneurs
are the world changers are the ones out
there making the difference being
equally happy with what we have as well
as frustrated that we want to go out and
do more and so that's what these
gratitude live streams relevant so I'm
going to share three things that I am
grateful for I want you guys share three
things that you are grateful for leaving
the live chat and also for those are you
guys watching the rebroadcast leave it
down the comments below important that
you actually feel it though as you think
about it ask yourself why why is this
important to you and I'm gonna start it
off I'm gonna get into your life
comments today is a special day for me
today I don't have three things to share
I have one where I'm changing it up a
little bit today because today is my
anniversary with Nina and we don't
celebrate our wedding anniversary I mean
we kind of did was August fifteenth but
we really as our anniversary count from
the day that we started dating and so
that was today a couple years ago more
than a couple years ago um what happened
was we met at Toronto dance salsa I
didn't
own the company yet it was just I was
just an investor in the company a
teacher of the company and I met Nina
there and we used to go out there these
socials that we had that we went out
after the social went for dinner and
Nina was there and I was there and we
started getting to know each feather and
chit chat and talking and one of the
things that really impressed me was her
story of coming to the country and how
it all happened I don't think in the
details but but she impressed me
nonetheless and just kind of everything
that she had gone through the lack of
complaining was something that was
really impressive because a lot of
people could have gone through that and
just complaining and complaining
complaining she didn't so that sparked
an initial interest there and if any of
you guys watched my seven ways video but
came out I think yesterday you'll see a
big change it happened in me the past
three years especially of doing video
and you know a lot of that has been
thanks to Nina too and just supporting
me and you know even if I had the crazy
ideas being willing to go along with it
and see what happens and some super
appreciative I'm super preciate the Nina
Shia maybe some surprises there's
there's four things that I have to eat
today that are from Nina the first i've
saved i'm going to eat right after this
is a these lentils with you can't really
see it from this angle but there's a
star-shaped egg and a heart-shaped egg
that she woke up early to make me this
morning maybe forehead not the so super
preciate of that and all the other
surprises that I'm sure are coming in
that in the fridge so yeah so it's a
it's it's in anniversaries I was a great
day to think back of all the exciting
things that have happened since you've
been together and Nina's always been by
my side always been supportive of me and
it's really it means a lot it means a
lot and she's here now hey
so that's what I got I have a happy
Anniversary cup of gratitude today is a
cup of gratitude and I think it did a
cup of gratitude I got some Rishi in my
head today so let's get to what you guys
have in a live chat jr. I start this off
what do you do before today I love a Jay
thanks for as leading the charge today
jay is thankful for the celebrities of
the world who serve a public examples
public examples to learn from for
longevity and youth which helps life be
vital and fun Jay's been the we've had
some interesting conversations about
longevity coaches for professional
athletes so as interesting is bringing
that up and for the inner guidance and
well being available to all I'm liking
that good job Zeno I'm grateful for our
number one soap cuz water alone isn't
enough I love it too almost having
finished my video just got to get the
ending right and then ask for feedback
pretty exciting excited for your video
man I'm sure there's a lot of people and
believe nation who would love to see it
and give you feedback if you want to
link it up in one of these live chats 3m
is live stream day always fun exciting
motivated and informative that's every
day every day is live stream day least
weekdays great job starting us off
boersma haveli aware Smith available it
seems oh he's here hey I'm here but
extremely busy just sending some
positive vibes to you guys appreciate
that man manju not hi everybody Rishi
morning everyone cup of love I love it
manjunath today I'm grateful for Evan
Carmichael I appreciate that man music
and books so important to you know I
think finding a way to incorporate that
your daily routine for me in the morning
i always put on some music just wakes me
up shakes me around put on stuff that i
want to groove to it puts me in a better
mood instantly so i think it's i think
it's super important and then books i
have a almost nightly ritual of reading
a little bit of a book before i go to
bed
we went and got his little nightlight so
we put next to our stand and then read a
breach the books when we go to sleep
unless it's some crazy late night or we
came back from a child and salsa event
then we don't but I think incorporating
music and books into your daily routine
is important we got what do we got what
do we got cup of good morning cup of
thunder clap it's official it's official
yes we can see yes thank you I know what
happened but my monitor blanked out at
the very start of this hi family in
nakuru hello hello Nina's here hi hello
and and the chat freaked out that
everybody knows that Nina's here happy
anniversary yes thank you everybody
thank you thank you awesome uh what do
we got cup of gratitude new future
builders in the house I miss new future
builders message sit there sky's the
limit great rise in everyone I'm
grateful for number one technology that
allows me to connect with believe nation
that is extremely important I'm google
for that too number tune Family Values
number three personal growth very cool
family incidentally is the one word of
trauma then salsa so I believe in family
values to Rishi cup TV number one I'm
thankful for all animals and loving
creatures I like that sometimes I call
Nina an animal Nina's an animal and 11
creature when she plays the legends her
name a special creature so she's a
loving animal and a special feature I
love horses and dogs I like that I like
I don't know what the horses I like I
like dogs I'm a dog person do we got
number two thankful for that cup there
in your background sitting sad and
lonely where's the cup in my background
Oh yesterday's starbucks there we go oh
she's thankful for it so we should put
it back we'll leave it there sad lonely
starbucks cup in the background what's
number three no number three okay it's
coming ah much I'm grateful for
supportive and encouraging friends I'm
group for healthy strong body to dance
and run and play with
I love that I'm grateful for a beautiful
fun family that I enjoy being with Jamie
want to see some dancing gen videos jen
has a YouTube channel talking about
copyrighting fantasy copywriting we want
to see some gin dancing videos I'm
excited nakuru thankful for my two books
on relationships coming soon awesome
congratulations and a bunch of laughs
and chatter have a great day guys horse
whisperer love it alright guys nine ten
thank you for joining me ah oui it's a
crazy day it's a crazy day of interviews
I think there's for hangouts on this
channel and one on the on the main
channel but coming up next we're heading
off the twitch for the live stream to
play league of legends but we answer
business questions hope you'll see you
there if not I'll see you later on at
another live stream I believe in you
guys I hope you believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon